what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are basically caught up with
guardians of the galaxy I mean there's
going to the galaxy grounded which is
like these little mini stories that show
what it is the guardians were doing like
while they were stuck on earth and it
actually kind of offers a somewhat of a
cool segue between what happened with
danos when he was captured during a
civil war - and like how he escapes
earth or at least when he goes against
the guardians of the galaxy which is
kind of a cool story in and of itself I
mean honestly it doesn't really amount
to much anyway just because of the fact
that we have like the Pharaohs
miniseries and then we have what's going
on or at least what we had going on and
unworthy for and all kinds of good stuff
- some of those actually kind of
conflicted to a degree oh by the way
I'll know if you guys are reading like
Thanos right now but it is amazing the
fan owes like to Thanos solo series it
is insanely good it's it's one of the
coolest things like Daniels versus the
Sun it's one of the coolest things ever
but anyway so with regards to really
Civil War - is what it is um this is
kind of pissed again are the guardians
really kind of embroiling and boiling
them in the Civil War - conflict there
we go
I cannot talk now the funny thing about
this is a Carol Danvers of course it
gets ahold of them says hey look guys
there is a conflict breaking out here
now I do have Civil War - down in the in
the description it wasn't a story that I
was partial to but it is kind of
important especially when it comes to
Captain America Steve Rogers part of the
whole Hydra story arc via Nick Spencer
it's really kind of like a
quintessential a necessity for
understanding everything that's going on
which by the way starting next Saturday
every Saturday is going to be basically
a catch-up video for Captain America
Steve Rogers the whole Hydra story arc
and we've got a little while until it
finishes I mean it's not going to finish
until like July or something like that
so we're just going to kind of start
with like cast away and dimension Z
which is basically like when he got a
son and then how he lost his Super
Soldier Serum and then all that kind of
good stuff we're actually going to
predate all-new all-different marvel
just a little bit just because I want
you guys to get a good idea but we'll
cross that bridge when we get to it but
the fact remains here it of course the
guardians of the galaxy being a team or
just kind of like look we have to vote
and we all have to agree whether or not
we're going to go so of course you know
they all end up going on up voting to
head out there but it's sort of a funny
situation because when they get there
they're immediately attacked by Carol
Danvers and and sword now a little bit
of explanation here for those of you
guys who are not familiar with the
different organizations and Marvel
Comics we've talked about this before so
have you been part of my channel when
we've run over these things bear with me
for a second because this whole this
will be a little bit of an explanation
but Marvel how
a lot of different organizations that
exist within the main Marvel continuity
and they will make a video kind of
running over all of them but shield is
the most well known of the organizations
the intelligence groups that exist for
the purpose of monitoring threats inside
the earth that's really shields only
purpose they monitor threats in the
earth now there was also Nick Fury as
the man on the wall and that was a story
that was covered during the whole
original sin who killed the watcher kind
of thing we basically found out that for
decades and decades Nick Fury was
traveling around the universe traveling
to other dimensions eliminating all
threats to the earth he was sort of
interesting in terms of Hell at all how
it all came together and I'm Adrian
Astor original sin at some point along
the line I just for the sake of our
whole you know Marvel cosmology next
year but the fact remains here that in
addition to shield which is monitors
earth-based threats you also have a
sword and Cynthia twirled observation
and response department basically just
does exactly what it sounds like since
Ian world it monitors other planets for
threats to the planet Earth now there
aren't other things you know where they
monitor other dimensions and so on and
so forth and you know you have these
different you know organizations here
and there but sword is basically just a
group that sits in a satellite and
watches everything unfold now of course
when the guardians of the galaxy are
brought into the sword base what this
does it's kind of refreshing us a little
bit with regards to what's going on and
all-new all-different marvel with Carol
Danvers remember when only one different
Marvel started she went away from just
being the earth-based superhero and
became the new director of sword
basically replacing Abigail brand now to
be honest with you guys I really hope
Abigail brand and sword is something
that we see in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because of the guardians of the
galaxy you would just make good sense
right I mean you know the events of
Thanos and so on and so forth I could
see them kind of adding those concepts
into the Marvel Universe we already have
shield and with Doctor Strange you could
introduce things like the you know
alternate reality monitoring and
operational response I think it is armor
is basically what it's called you can
just bring in organizations because
armor exists to monitor other dimensions
other realities so I mean there's all
different kinds of things that you could
do with the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but I digress we're going off on a
tangent talking about Marvel movies when
we should be talking about guardians of
the galaxy so Carol Danvers basically
leads a sword now and of course you end
up having Alpha Flight now of course the
funny thing about this is that Alpha
Flight was at best like a c-list
team I mean if alpha flight showed up in
a story it's like okay well then this
time we move on to something else
because I never really cared about Alpha
Flight it's kind of cool to see them in
this story though or at least in all new
marble because I've kind of been taken
out of the realm as like a poor man's
Avengers based out of Canada and now
they're effectively a more reasonable
team based out of you know space more or
less but they go on like these
interesting missions and so on but the
fact remains here the Carol Danvers
basically pulls Peter quill aside and
gives him the rundown on everything
that's happening so of course he
basically fills an in on the lead up to
Civil War - now if those are guys who
haven't been reading any of that or who
are kind of jumping on board with Marvel
for the first time a civil works who was
a story that caused a lot of division
among the comic books injury some loved
it some absolutely hated it but
regardless it was basically this idea
that an inhuman named Ulysses had popped
up and it basically had these
premonitions and there were all
different kinds of studies that were
done as to whether or not they were
accurate or anything like that but the
idea was that Ulysses was essentially
just kind of saying hey look this attack
is going to happen and there were two or
three instances where it proved to be
absolutely true the first was this
dimensional you know celestial that
showed up on earth another was stano's
and there were a few few more conflicts
here and there but each time he proved
me right however there were instances
that he proved to be wrong now on the
front side with Civil War - the way it
was written it was Carol Danvers and it
was Tony Stark's battling one another
over whether or not pre-crime should be
brought into the equation which is to
say Carol Danvers we'll listen was
absolute certainty - what it is Ulysses
says and then act on it whereas Tony
Stark was saying you can't arrest people
for crimes they haven't committed yet
even if a person says he knows it's
going to happen you have to let them
commit that crime and then arrest them
for something that are actually guilty
of now on the backside Steve Rogers knew
everything that was going on he realized
what was happening and he came to
realization almost immediately that your
lyses predictions were not 100% accurate
but in order for Hydra to secure itself
and effectively take over the world
begin the process of dominating shield
and then eventually taking over the
world in its entirety Steve Rogers
actually egged on the conflict between
Carol Danvers and Tony Stark pitting
them at heads more and more to the point
that if civil war broke out and the idea
was that following the Civil War that
the superhero community would be
fractured and it would be broken they
would be so split in terms of what's
right and what's wrong that would allow
Steve Rogers to basically finesse
himself in implement all these different
plans bring in a shield and so on and so
forth that the superheroes would just
kind of jump at any opportunity to keep
the earth protected and make sure that
they're showing themselves as being
heroes they wouldn't stop to ask the
question if Steve Rogers actually doing
the right thing so again it was
cool what Nick Spencer did on the back
end and I feel like Captain America
Civil War Captain America Steve Rogers
definitely made the Civil War story a
lot more interesting than it was I
really felt like I could have been a
main part of the story instead of a
tie-in but regardless of how those
events turned out the funny thing is
that there's a lot of debate going back
and forth because remember Kitty Pryde
has been gone all this time so she
doesn't know about Inhumans vs. x-men
she doesn't know about the Terrigen
clouds spreading across the earth and
killing mutants she doesn't know about
the death of Cyclops she doesn't know
about all these things that have been
going on because she's been with the
Guardians before all of this even
happened and so what's kind of weird
about this is that businesses are really
portraying the shocking nature the way
we would expect it to you know and this
is a kitty pryde is just like I've been
with the actions as I was 13 years old
you would think she'd be a little more
shocked a little more stunned at
everything that's happening the other
half of this is that Kitty Pryde is also
talking directly with star-lord about
Thanos now this was kind of a funny
situation and I feel like Brian Michael
Bendis may have forgotten something here
something is actually kind of pivotal
when it comes to Drax the destroyer and
as soon as I saw that I was like that's
a pretty big glaring miss but the idea
here is that Peter quill has been told
by Carol Danvers that Thanos is on earth
Gamora will hunt Thanos to the ends of
the universe in order to kill and it's
the one thing that she wants to do more
than any other is eliminate her adoptive
father now the crazy thing about this is
that Peter quill doesn't tell her and
he's kind of debating this I mean this
is a struggle for him it's not it's not
a throwaway thing it's not like he's
like we'll get around to when we get
around to it for him it's more of a
significant thing where it's just like
if I don't tell her and she finds out
she'll lose trust in me in her entirety
but if we're going to be part of the
Civil War thing her head needs to be
clear and she needs to not be thinking
about Thanos because if she finds out
panels is on earth she'll leave us and
go find a nose and try to kill him at
the same time it's loyalties ultimately
Peter quill decides not to tell her but
Kitty Pryde says you need to now this is
basically going to lay the groundwork
for the guardians of the galaxy
essentially fracturing because what's
going to happen is that the more is
basically going to walk away now again
we'll get to that here in a second but
with regards to the main conflict itself
it's actually kind of funny the way that
the way that this is done by Bendis
course we know about the main civil war
story so of course Carol Danvers
basically shows up and says hey guys
getting ready to make moves everybody's
getting ready to fight we don't even see
the conflict we just see that like 15
minutes or 14 minutes after it's
the guardians of the galaxy ship blows
up 36 minutes later rocket returns so
bent out of shape he's like we just lost
everything we own
like it's like it's sad but it's funny I
mean it's kind of messed up it's
interesting because now they're
effectively stuck on earth but what's so
ironic about this is that the earth
itself does not have the ability to
achieve interstellar travel there are
people that can teleport around to
different places throughout you know the
entirety of the universe but it doesn't
have the interstellar travel the reason
why this is so significant is because of
the fact that has been discount of
hitting home again at the idea that the
earth is primitive now we're going to
find out how primitive the earth is
viewed by other races here in a little
bit especially Annihilus when they just
kind of bail out on their decision to
try to attack the earth but ultimately
the revelation of Thanos being on earth
comes to a head when Gamora overhears
some of the soldiers talking and one of
them says they want an update on Stannis
you know as soon as possible because
remember the Triskelion which is the
main base of operations for the ultimate
was essentially kind of obliterated in
the conflict but Thanos has helped miles
underground and so of course you know
with him being held there the idea is to
make sure that he's still intact because
remember if Thanos gets freed I'm going
to go out a little limb and I'm going to
make this claim if damage were to be
freed right now in this story as it
stands at this moment if he's at full
power
none of the superheroes would be able to
stop him not one he would literally tear
through all of them because he's just
that damn powerful he's just that
durable I mean it really begs the
question if Thanos were to run amok on
earth and we were taking away like story
in the story or taking away like plot
devices like when Ironman first bought
Stannis when Thanos first appeared in
Marvel Comics and it turned out to be a
robot or something like that if Thanos
at full strength went against all the
superheroes on earth at full strength
barring any of the reality Wars could
Thanos win and my response would be
probably I mean if we got like a
no-holds-barred there was no plot
involved well Thanos has to lose because
that's what the story calls for you know
if it was just like let's just write it
and see what happens you know we're just
kind of compared feats I would say fan
o's would probably come out on top
against the entirety of the earth
superheroes
it's a bold statement it I'm sure
there's going to be people who were just
like wow you're insane but I really
think he would I really really think
he'd be capable of doing that um but
this is why I say Bendis seems to have
missed a pretty glaring issue because
rubber Drax the destroyer can find fan
anywhere in the universe no matter where
Santos goes Drax will sense it it's the
basis behind its creation
when Drax a destroyer when when Arthur
Douglas was first transformed in the
Drax a destroyer
one of the tools that was given to him
was the ability to locate Thanos
anywhere in the cosmos and so you know
you would think that even if it was only
a statement and passing or something
like that Drax the destroyer would be
like does everybody know that Thanos is
here like are you guys aware that Thanos
is here you think you would have just
told someone you know not only that Drax
gets stronger the closer he gets to
Thanos because you know he exists for
the purpose of killing Thanos so again
you would think he would have known it
would have said something you know or
just been about anybody else realized
that's what's going on here the fact
that it wasn't brought up kind of brings
two possibilities the first is that
ventus didn't think it mattered or the
second is that maybe you just forgot I
have no idea but Venice does kind of
have a tendency to write stories as he
believes the character should be as
opposed to how the characters have
previously been written and so sometimes
you run the continuity errors where
suddenly character is had a certain
power or certain ability for 20 years
and then bindus writes a story and
suddenly they don't and so it is one of
those weird situations that you run into
from time to time it's not to take away
from him as a writer he's still a great
writer you know it's just one of those
things you run into occasionally and a
lot of writers end up in that in that
role but once Gamora learns that Thanos
is on earth she goes on a warpath I mean
it's insane like she takes on all of
these shield forces now force this leads
directly to the arrival of Carol Danvers
and it actually pits a two against one
another I keep in mind Carol Danvers is
insanely strong and durable when it
comes when it comes down to it she can
go toe-to-toe with the Incredible Hulk
in his base form now again much like our
discussion with Ben Grimm don't reach it
though there will come a point where the
Incredible Hulk will just be so strong
that Carol Danvers won't be able to
overcome him I mean that's just kind of
the way that goes seeing her going
toe-to-toe with Gamora it's kind of
interesting but only insofar that Carol
is able to able to overpower Gamora in a
couple of different ways and the reason
why I say that is because remember
Gamora is a really good fighter and
she's really you know really capable but
she can't fly she has some measure of
strength of super strength but she's
nowhere near the same level as Carol
Danvers and Carol Danvers has the
ability to absorb and project almost any
form of energy so keeping the more a bay
is the first step and then constantly
bombarding her with energy blast is the
next
no this is really what what Carol
Danvers does to effectively topple her
phone now once it comes down to it
because of the fact that Gomorrah just
will not stop trying to attack Thanos
trying to get to Thanos missiles really
leads to gomorrah and carol danvers
going head to head and physical punches
and this is really just kind of a
confirmation that ultimately Carol
Danvers is just stronger than Gomorrah
you know Gomorrah just cannot take Carol
Danvers down which is kind of ironic
because we know Gomorrah as the
deadliest assassin in the galaxy really
the deadliest woman in the galaxy and
the title is still maintained the way
that Bendis right cysts and the reason
why I say that is because of the fact
that deadliest does not necessarily mean
strongest it does not necessarily mean
the most powerful you could easily
replace the word deadliest with ruthless
and you would still have the exact same
principle gomorrah will kill her target
no questions asked if somebody goes to
Mora and says I want to pay you then
absorbent in you know exorbitant sum of
money to go kill this person Gomorrah
will do it as long as it doesn't you
know conflict with their own moral
compass she will do it and that person
will be dead and that money will be paid
in this scenario we see her trying to
track down and take out Thanos and
she'll fight anybody who gets in her way
it's the fact that she'll keep coming
back until she's killed that makes her
so ruthless and makes her so deadly as
one of the things about the marvel
cinematic universe version of Gomorrah
did I enjoy so much I think thinking
more in the MCU should be deadlier I
think that she should be a little more
capable of a fighter that she already is
um I think that her kind of going
against nebula is interesting but I
don't think that Gamora fighting against
nebula in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
really showcases what she's capable of
so hopefully we see her pulling out some
big feats and guardians of the galaxy
too but regardless once Carol Danvers
kind of mutters to herself the idea that
Peter flow was right that that she
should have said something to Gamora
ultimately you know good moreover here's
what it is a Carol said and essentially
just kind of a chase and says all right
that's it I'm done I don't want to have
anything to do with the guardians of the
galaxy I want to have anything to do
with Peter quill I don't have anything
to do with allies you know in the
misinformation that he's peddling I am
I'm not to be contacted by you and I'm
not to be contacted by him it's her
essentially walking away from everything
and that's really the way it goes when
it comes to the other members of the
guardians Drax the destroyer looks at
Peter quill and says Gamora is a friend
you know more so than that she's family
the fact that you would hide that
information the fact that you would lie
it means that we can't trust you anymore
Rocket Raccoon group they take the exact
same stamp and effectively the guardians
of the galaxy completely disband now all
this really comes to a head with regards
to like Annihilus because remember
Annihilus is kind of been plotting to to
take over her keel to conquer earth and
so on and so forth and invade the
universe but then he was launching the
entirety of civil war to unfold he's
like nah man those clowns don't even
have their own planet together like do
we really want to meddle with these
goofballs it's also where they just kind
of call it a day if they're just going
to walk away which was just kind of a
funny saying what this does is it
actually sets the stage for Jerry Duggan
to take over guardians of the galaxy now
there is a story called grounded and
again ground is just kind of it's kind
of like these little many stories that
talks about what the guardians were
doing while they were on earth so we may
or may not cover that I mean in terms of
the guardians of the galaxy as they
exist as a team this is basically the
end of it until Jerry Duggan picks up
when we kind of move in an X direction I
mean there is the new star Lords story
and that kind of thing going on but with
regards to the Guardians per se for the
most part they kind of disbanded with
grounded and we're just you know they're
going to get that together later on down
the line and we know that'll happen but
I'll have it just in time for the
release of the movie but if you guys are
new here to come in to explain make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you